what's going on guys
so it seems like you really enjoyed our
before they were famous episodes where
we showcased commercials that
celebrities did before they blew up but
you kept asking what about those weird
foreign commercial celebrities do thanks
to the internet we got them and we're
proud to present to you salute
first up multi Oscar winner Daniel
day-lewis advertises some kind of
Japanese drink Sunita Zico it's pure did
a fun fact to prepare for that
commercial Daniel day-lewis lived in
that lake for three months one thing we
can all agree on is that Nicolas Cage is
a lunatic but where do you see him in
these Japanese commercials he ain't seen
nothing yet
company in a good book the dance the
rain there and also Jacob yeah Chico
Chico wah we ship let's shrimp
tell this you can make it sound good
I think we can just move on from those
here's dr. house Hugh Laurie for
Schweppes maybe Bonnie don't miss Peter
oh no you get it down Schweppes
that's Wilton look no yellow Sabha in
this finger waves Estonia musk read on
what have scraps
Wow Swiss blue SK hey uh know me at the
air cos you're ugly don't get cocky
yo anybody else do a Schweppes
commercial yeah uma Thurman
I love Schweppes I need to have it all
the time I like to have Schweppes with
strangers would you have some Schweppes
just me and you
I'm sorry humor but you mean sex right
god no shrubs shrubs you know what I
always wondered the Numa Thurman ever
have Schweppes with Quentin Tarantino
and now the commercial king of Japan
Arnold Schwarzenegger let's take a look
at some of his biggest hits Jim Bowie
boy
oh shut up
you John
please
boy boy boy boy is it just me or is that
the best acting Schwarzenegger has ever
done
well if Arnold Schwarzenegger is the
king of Japanese commercials that means
Leonardo DiCaprio is you know here's Leo
at a European phone commercial that
plays like a mini Inception I saw her
again
we're gonna find her I've gotta find out
what happened
now you're probably saying Oh Leo didn't
do commercials in any other countries
yay did Italy watch this
I mean that course may be itchy here's
Leo for everyone's favorite Japanese
credit card or Rico
okay Kato who
Mariko Kart okay
leonardo dicaprio hollywood star by day
japanese detective by night
check out ben stiller proving there's
something about Kirin beer
don't get fresh
okay so it's not enough for you that
derek zoolander endorses Kirin beer what
about Han Solo
sorry mr. JD Navabi here's Eddie Murphy
for toyota celica have you try the new
Celica check out the silver silver back
the duel mode full wheel steering again
1u Celica 2 things have happened since
this commercial Toyota stop making
Celicas and Eddie Murphy stop making
good movies those are weird
so what celebrity would you want to send
to a foreign country to do a commercial
and what would you want to see him do
leave us an answer in the comments
section below even describe the
commercial you want to see best answer
you're going to get a screen junkies
t-shirt Hey
and while you're here check out our
honest trailer for 300 it happens to be
our 50th honest trailer good job guys
that's our golden anniversary thanks
everybody for watching I'm Hal Rudnick
check me out on Twitter bye bye
tell me about the Rocket Raccoon Oh
Rocket Raccoon I think is gonna be the
star of the movie I mean you have a
talking raccoon as a smartass
this one is our food is the Wolverine of
the movie